hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from round 11 of this
year's U.S Championship there are 13
Rounds in total so two more will be
played and it is hand smoke and Iman
versus Alexander Linderman and as the
title suggests a very good moves were
played in this game uh so let's check it
out I'm sure you guys will enjoy it uh
Hans opens with Ponte D4 now Alexander
replies with Ponte D5 we have C for C6
going for the slop defense Knight F3
Knight to F6 and now Pawn to E3 we have
Bishop to G4 pinning the Knight and
Knight the C3 we have pawned the E6 now
the bishop has been developed so you can
put your points on light cores and the
dark Square Bishop will be able to roam
freely in between H3 Bishop to H5 and
now G4 as this is 2022 we are not tried
to push our pawns Bishop to G6 and now
Knight the E5 an excellent Square for
the Knight we have Knight beat the D7
and now Hans just grabs the bishop on G6
you don't don't have to capture it you
could continue pushing with something
like H4 H5 and it has been played before
but this is considered the best so
Knight captures with age captures and
pawn to G5 grabbing more space on the
king side and H4 will cement that pawn
on G5 so Knight E4 Knight captures the
captures and pawn to H4 now we have
Bishop to B4 with check Bishop to D2 and
now Queen to A5 so again nothing new
here all been played before Ponte A3
attacking the bishop Bishop captures on
D2 Queen captures and now we have a
queen trade captures captures and pawn
to F5 now this is the absolute best move
and again this has all been played
before Pawn to C5 grabbing more space
here and also freeing up the C4 Square
for the bishop and it might seem like
you're uh creating a sort of an outpost
on D5 for the for the Black Knight the
problem is the Knight doesn't really
have a way of reaching the D5 Square you
can't go to B6 then a D5 you can't go to
F6 then to D5 so for the moment the D5
is not an issue and there is a game
where Wesley so played uh against David
Nevada and Nevada played Rook to d8 and
Wesley was able to win that game but
here we have King the E7 by Lenderman
the uh best move by the engine so
obviously he improved on the game Nevada
played against Wesley so and now again
there is a game that the ding lyron
played against even shotico where Bishop
to C4 was played right away the game
ended in a draw but here Hans knows uh
what's what and he goes for Pawn to B4
and now there are a few games where A6
was played but here we have Rook a to d8
and it is now as of move a team that we
have a completely new game and this is
where our game basically begins so King
to C3 uh improving the position of the
king we have Pawn to E5 you have to
figure out how to get this Knight into
the game like I said you can't go B6 you
can't go here you can go here uh I mean
you can but there are Pawns in G6 and E6
so by playing E5 you will trade down
this Pawn for the D4 pawn and you have
also created an outpost on E6 for your
knight and okay Bishop to C4 we have e
Captain D for E captors and now Knight
to fade this is a landerman I will
activate the Knight we have Pawn to F3
the one the blacking is in the center of
the board so of course we want to open
up lines in front of the king e captures
an F3 and now Rook a to F1 First You're
Gonna grab the pawn and then you're
gonna go after the king for the moment
uh the the the the white Rook on H1 has
to remain here to guard the this Pawn uh
so you have to play the other Rook to F1
we have King to D7 Rook captures on F3
and now only now Knights the E6 and here
uh Hans has to figure out whether he
wants to play a rook end game or he
prefers keeping the bishop and Knight on
the board now uh countering the Knight
is not a terrible move yeah it can
actually be played in you you can get
quite a lot of play from this for
example characters captures now Rook the
E3 with check and of course you can't go
here because if you go here Rook to E5
is Checkmate so you would have to go up
the board and after you go King to D7 or
something like this then Pawn to D5 you
give up a pawn to free up the D4 Square
for the king and Okay C captures King to
D4 and now the problem is you can't
really defend the pawn you can't go here
you can't go here if you go here then
Rook the E6 check picks up the G6 Pawn
then G7 is weak F5 is weak so it would
be Troublesome to play for example F4
Rook to F3 you can play Rook D to f8 now
uh and now okay King Capital Sun D5 and
you will get this position still equal
material uh white white should be a
little bit better but still nothing
spectacular you can't really activate
the Rook because this Pawn is constantly
hanging uh so it you know it's fine but
definitely not much so instead after
this Knight the E6 move Hans goes Rook
to E1 for the moment it's okay to leave
the H4 Pawn on free because the Knight
on E6 is hanging so all night the C7 now
preparing to come to D5 with check and
now Rook the H3 now this Rook comes to
help out with the defense of the H Pawn
and now uh Rook to d8 interestingly if
you go Knight to D5 check right away
it's not all that great for example
Bishop captures C characters and rookie
five again how do you defend the pawn
there's no good way of doing it you can
go here again you can't go here because
of check picking up the G6 spawn so
you'd have to go up the board and then
Rook E7 and then if Rook D7 Rook E6 goes
after the G6 spawn so this would uh this
would be winning for white so you have
to be very very careful you want to
activate your knight but not in a way
that it loses you the game so rook dte8
and now Rook capture Sunny 8 uh King
captures this Rook should remain here uh
so the the white hook cannot be
activated and now Pawn to A4 uh you do
have a four to three advantage on the
queen side so maybe if those pawns just
you know start marching forward you will
at some point end up with a past pawn
and now King to D7 again Knights the D5
check is an option but we don't like it
pawn to B5 and now we have Knight to E6
uh so what's the idea behind Knight E6
obviously a knight captures on G5 is a
threat then if H captures the rook and
H3 will hang but Hans just plays King
the B4 he says you can have the G Pawn
I'm going for I'm going all out here and
can the can the pawn be captured here
you could capture it but it then comes
Rook to G3 attacking the Knight and then
the Knight moves you you lose the G6
font so again it's not spectacular
another thing you could do is play
Knight captures on D4 but then Rook to
D3 uh pins the Knight now you can't move
the Knight and if your captures
defending the Knight King the C3 and now
the Knight definitely hangs so instead
we have Knights the F4 attacking The
Rook Rook to H2 and now King the C7 so
Slenderman playing absolute best
defensive moves Here pawn to A5 Hans
continues pushing on the queen side C
captures with Bishop captures and now
Pawn to A6 chasing away the Dasha but
now Bishop to A4 and this is what Hans
wanted to achieve he wanted to get to
the pass deep on he has the D6 Square
guarded by the pawn he has the D7 Square
guarded by the bishop and now he will at
some point start pushing this Pawn so
Knights the E6 goes after the D4 Pawn
also the G5 Pawn now maybe and pawn to
D5 offering the G5 pawn and now okay a
knight captures on G5 and what do you
play now the problem is if you go Rook
to G2 now then Rook captures and H Force
comes with checks so you don't really
have to worry about the Knight hanging
here so instead after this Knight
captures on G5 move Hans plays Pawn to
D6 with check and now this is the moment
where it all happens the the position is
actually a draw but you have to play you
you have to play uh a perfect move and
now just for fun feel free free to pause
the video here and try to find the
absolute best move for black while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on putting the king
anywhere except on d8 the king to C8 is
best King to B8 is uh or maybe maybe
even King the beat can be played but
King should be a bit closer to the
action so King to see it is a move you
have to play now I will show why because
Slenderman played King to d8 so
congratulations to everyone who decided
against King 38 even though it kind of
seems like a reasonable move but the
problem is and it's really crazy after
King the C8 point is that now after you
play c6b characters and Bishop captures
look at this all of these squares are
now covered by the bishop and by the
pawn uh there's uh not all that much you
can do here and even if you don't
capture right away even if King the C5
you want to improve the position of your
king let's say Knight E4 check and King
to C6 uh there's Rook to d8 and this is
the main problem for white because now
uh the pawn is hanging here and you
can't really save it the the Knight and
the Rook are attacking it the bishop
does not guard the D7 Square for you to
push the pawn to D7 and the Knight also
prevents Rook to D2 as the Knight covers
the D2 Square so that's why King the C8
is so amazing as it allows The Rook to
come to d8 but in the game Linderman
played a king the d8 uh and well now at
the end of that line we will be missing
that Rook to d8 move so here pontacy six
by Hans B captures on C6 and now King to
C5 uh you can't really defend the the
the the pawn here there's no way to do
it if you go here where of course just
Bishop captures with the check and if
you don't like the E4 which check just
King captures on C6 and now again all of
these squares are covered The Rook to B2
is coming Rook to B8 uh Unstoppable
threats here so Slenderman tried to go
for some counter-attacking ideas with
Pawn to F4 but now Rook to B2 by Hans
and the problem is uh you can't defend
uh if you if you go for some like Rook
captures on H4 there's always the nasty
will be to check King to D7 Bishop
captures and C6 would check King to E6
and now Bishop to D5 check if King back
to D7 Rook B7 checked King to E8 and now
just King to C6 taking away the D7
Square from the black king and look at
this all of these squares are covered by
the pawn by the bishop by the king and
Rook the V8 will be Checkmate there's no
way to no way to prevent this you could
try this tricky Knight to F7 move but uh
I mean uh just Bishop capture Sun F7 of
course white is not silly so after Rook
to B2 Knights the E6 check this was one
final attempt by landerman and now King
captures on C6 Knight to D4 with check
King to D5 and now Knight the B5 uh
blocking the B file so The Rook does not
have Rook to B8 but not just Bishop
captures Pawn captures and now King the
C6 there are also other moves you could
also start pushing the pawn but this is
much cleaner for example if A6 F3 A7 you
can play King seven null Rook regards
the queening square which is still
winning for white but you you give black
too much ideas so Hans plays it
perfectly King to C6 and now after King
the E8 uh just came to C7 uh going after
the D7 check move so King F7 Pawn to D7
and he was in this position on move 45
that Alexander Linderman resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so brilliant brilliant a game by
Hans uh going uh for the end game
basically right out of the opening 18
moves of pure Theory and then improving
unexisting Theory uh and then just
playing a perfect end game so there was
a way for for Landrum to save it but you
know that came to see it or King to the
eight move it was not not an easy choice
to make so here you resign because
whatever you do and really doesn't
matter let's say Pawn to F3 just the d8
queen and after you give up The Rook you
are just the upper full Rook of course
The Rook is more than capable of
handling all of these pawns and that's
just it
uh so yeah after the seven alignment
resigns and a wonderful victory for Han
smoking Iman in round 11 of the US
Championship 2022. now what does this
mean for the standing sons did not have
a great start to determine but now he
picks up his second win in a row and uh
there are two more rounds to go so we'll
see what happens the leader of the
tournament still Fabiana corvana with
seven and a half points uh followed by
uh Ray Robson with seven points and then
Samuel Savion and linear Dominguez with
uh six and a half so we'll see what
happens two more rounds to go uh who
will be the the US champion of 2022. uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it as you can see it's very
important to study the end game because
even if you know 20 moves of of pure
Theory and you play a nice middle game
and there's always the end game waiting
for you uh so yeah once again hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to wish a
very happy birthday to Jimmy LeBlanc and
I would like to thank Anderson Vira
torko stand with ravishing reptiles
YouTube and Trevor Terrace for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event and whatever else
happens in the Chess World thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day